dixie we are shining shimmering splendid
who are we wearing
raw for so what made you choose a little
sparkle tonight and tell me about this
eye look what were you going for
um i just we've been inside for a very
long time why not
shine the time as we come out i'm i
always wear
really dark clothes so yeah i love it
um so you're presenting tonight right
tell me what you're presenting and who
you're excited to see
i'm presenting a performance
and i'm excited for that and i just saw
dozier perform on the tv and i'm very
excited that i saw that i love her so
much
i mean you're an artist as well so is
there anybody who you're gonna see and
say hi would you like to collab
um i probably won't say that i probably
will just like
look at them and then freak out later
but i'm so
excited and grateful because i've looked
up for a lot of these people for so long
so
okay if you could meet one person
tonight who is it um
maybe dj khaled i feel like that's just
really cool he loves a collab so i see
this happening
i would love that i would also just love
to say hi
but if he's if he wants to collab i'm
here
so we are also soon going to be seeing
your show
the trailer has dropped what was it like
filming and what can people expect
um filming was very weird
nothing that you would think but i think
what people are expecting is another
reality show drama and it's not that
it's the real
emotions and feeling that our family
feels and goes through every day that
i'm
excited to share with the world we're
giving up a lot of our privacy and our
personal lives but i think it's going to
be cool for people to see
what will they learn about you that they
don't know already
i think there's a lot of random facts
thrown in there sometimes in my
interviews i'll say something they're
like wait
what um i'm just excited for it
and i mean look i think people love your
family they're excited to see it
what did did you have any apprehension
though even though you share a lot about
your lives
did you have apprehension about having
cameras following you around all the
time and did you seek advice from
anybody i mean
the kardashians have been on tv for
years tons of people did you say can
anyone give me any tips here
um well the people who actually um are
producing my show and the show runner of
my show have worked on shows that i've
watched and i'm like
how did you do that how am i am i doing
okay and
i'm excited for people to get a closer
look into our lives and not just 15
second videos i think it'll be
great awesome give me a little spin for
the camera if you can let's see this
yeah oh the back the back you're giving
me audrey hepburn vibes with this hair
oh
thank you thank you thank you so much